>>Rachel: My name is Rachel
Arthur, I teach ninth grade English,
and I'm also the ninth
grade level chair.
>>Friar Lawrence is
really upset, right?
Why would Friar Lawrence be so upset?
>>The students really got
into, "Romeo and Juliet."
I just started with teaching
them about Shakespeare,
William Shakespeare, the person,
and then also we just talked
about Elizabethan terms,
versus contemporary terms,
so they can get familiar
with that language.
>>What do you think are some
problems that might arise in the fact
that Romeo has not
received the letter yet?
>>As we were reading through the
story, we were collecting evidence,
whether it was characterization
or just different events
that happened throughout the play,
so that they can piece
together an analysis paper
by the end of the unit.
>>Tell me a couple of
predictions that you guys had.
>>And we also had some
creative outlets for them,
where they were able to translate
it into contemporary terms.
>>Student: What means the world
to you, being lost for a guy,
or being lost for a girl?
To the world, you just mean somebody,
but to somebody, you mean the world.
>>Rachel: They created
their own sonnets.
A lot of people made poems
or raps, or you know,
just visual representations, just
to show their artistic expression.
>>You connect one or two
of them to, you know,
the tragedy that happened at the end?
>>Each year I feel like I've figured
out a way to kind of make it relevant
to what's going on in their life.
>>Student: Every time that she
looked at Romeo, she saw love.
So there's a heart in the eye,
to signify love at first sight.
>>Rachel: I think one of the
great things that we do at YES,
is build positive relationships.
We take time, whether it's
during the school day or outside
of the school day, to really
get to know our students,
and the students know the
expectations and they recognize
that they need this education to get
to the place that they want to go to.
A lot of them are going back
home to, you know, neighborhoods,
where they see the other side.
They see what happens if they
don't go to a school like YES,
and they don't get to go off to
college and get that successful job.
They love being in an environment
where they have teachers who care
about them, and care about their
success, and they feed off of that,
so when you walk into a classroom,
you will see students, you know,
engaged and participating
and what not,
because they know this is their
ticket to something great.
>>Have you ever seen someone who's
in love, and they lost someone,
and they just commit suicide?
Frequently?
>>This job is absolutely worth it.
It's challenging, I'm not going
to say that it's not challenging.
We definitely have long hours,
and we put a lot of work,
even when we go home at the end
of the day, we're still thinking
about YES, but it's worth it, because
we see the change that's happening,
not only to individual
students and to their families,
but even just our city is starting
to transform, as they realize,
we have a problem with the
education system, and at YES,
we're doing something to change it.
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.